this detective Alex Murphy officer down
we are on the eve of a technological
revolution we need to give Americans
figure they can rally behind me give you
mommy kiss my baby too slow boy we're
gonna put a man inside a machine
he suffered fourth-degree burns over
eighty percent of his body if he
survives he'll be paralyzed from the
waist down confined to a world champ you
say you can save him what does that mean
what kind of life really happen
considers this it's smart it's you the
hell did you do to me
make a more practical make them look
let's go with black
when the Machine fights sleep system
releases sickness into Alex's rang
making him think he's in control but
he's not it's the illusion of free will
I've selected 13 targets all wanted for
murder
this is the future of American justice
you need to speak to your son
wow he's overwriting the system's
priorities the human element will always
be present compassion fear instinct they
will always interfere with the system
general I
you're coming with me
you